pero si ampliamos nuestro punto de vista,
un grifo que gotea en nuestra cocina,
un radiador roto en nuestro pasillo,
aquellas partes de la casa que siempre dejamos para a la próxima semana,
están devaluando toda nuestra propiedad.
En vez de estar vislumbrando soluciones como la privatización
o el movimiento de escuelas chárter para resolver nuestros problemas,
¿por qué no miramos con más detenimiento la educación pública,
para estar más orgullos de ella
y tal vez utilizarla para resolver algunos de nuestros problemas sociales?
¿Por qué no tratamos de recuperar la promesa de la educación pública
y de recordar que es nuestra mayor responsabilidad colectiva?
Por suerte algunas de nuestras comunidades hacen precisamente eso.
Las grandes huelgas de maestros en el 2019 en Denver y Los Ángeles,
tuvieron éxito debido al apoyo de la comunidad
logrando reducir el número de niños por clase
y obteniendo más consejeros
además de mejorar los salarios de los maestros.
Y a veces para el estudiante,
la innovación es atreverse a poner en práctica el sentido común.
En Baltimore hace unos años,
promulgaron un programa de desayuno y almuerzo gratis,
quitando el estigma de la pobreza y el hambre
a algunos estudiantes
logrando aumentar el rendimiento en la asistencia para muchos otros.
Y en Memphis,
la universidad recluta estudiantes de secundaria apasionados locales
dándoles becas para ir a enseñar en el interior de la ciudad
sin la carga de la deuda de la universidad.
Y en el norte de aquí, en el Bronx,
recientemente he investigado estas asociaciones que se construyen
entre escuelas secundarias, colegios comunitarios y empresas locales
que crean prácticas en las finanzas, la salud y la tecnología
para estudiantes sin conexiones privilegiadas
para así obtener habilidades importantes
y contribuir a las comunidades que vienen.
Así que hoy no necesariamente tengo las mismas preguntas sobre la educación
que me planteaba cuando era un idealista, o un titulado universitario ingenuo
trabajando en un sótano de un centro de detención.
No es: ¿pueden las escuelas salvar a más de nuestros estudiantes?
Porque creo que tenemos la respuesta.
Y es que sí, si salvamos primero nuestras escuelas.
Podemos empezar preocupándonos por la educación de los hijos de otros.
Y lo digo como alguien que no tiene hijos todavía,
pero que quiere preocuparse un poco menos en el futuro cuando los tenga.
El cultivo de tanto talento como es posible,
llevando al mayor número de niñas como es posible
a la ciencia y la ingeniería,
tantos chicos como posible a la enseñanza
esas son las inversiones para nuestro futuro.
Nuestros estudiantes son como nuestro recurso más valioso,
y cuando se enfoca de esa manera,
nuestros maestros son hoy en día como nuestros diamantes y mineros de oro
con esperanza de que ayuden a brillar.
Vamos a contribuir con nuestras voces,
nuestros votos y nuestro apoyo
para darles los recursos necesarios
no solo para sobrevivir
sino para prosperar,
permitiéndonos a todos hacer lo mismo.
Gracias.
(Aplausos y ovaciones)